some of these offers i wrote or the
emails things that i wrote it's just
like this is complete
[ __ ] they test which story works
worth or works best you know the
researcher from arizona didn't work
let's try the the crazy doctor from uh
you know from texas
uh it's not going so good maybe let's
try the researcher with this thing you
know so they'll change the personality
they'll change the entire story
to find one that hits you know i was
mike
my father-in-law was on the plane and
you know he had a massive heart attack
and at 784 pounds
well none of this is true this is not
true yeah and a binder hit me on the
head and i
put a rare herb inside of his mouth
you know wouldn't you know it 10 days
later he lost the weight
we don't talk about copywriters very
much but we should because they're an
important part
of scams there's ethical copywriting
obviously
but increasingly i've noticed a trend
especially in direct response
copywriting
which is a lot of what you see today on
clickbank and in click funnels
there's a more unethical kind going on
which is focused on conversions at any
cost
make up any story you want do anything
you need to do
to get the sale and so to understand how
the psychology of this works
how people can get trapped in this
lifestyle we're going to talk to
somebody who was this is
jim claire he's been in the industry for
over 10 years and he's about to explain
how he was seduced by the money and the
lifestyle of this industry
how he eventually got out of it and he's
going to share some funny stories about
this insane world as we go along
i hope you enjoy so i got into it uh
with a company called the dao of badass
i
got into it on the dating side and then
i worked with
primarily primarily my offers and where
i worked
with the click clickbank people oh those
people are
lovely people lovely people ethical
people
very ethical yeah that's yeah
clinkbank is a unique uh
echo chamber for sure can you tell
people what clickbank is for those who
don't know
like what do they sell right so
clickbank they call themselves a digital
retailer and it's primarily direct
marketing offers and they sell right now
i think yeah as of the other day there's
about 3578
products sold on clickbank so someone
can sell a health product someone can
sell
a uh you know a make money online
product there's not a ton of them on
there anymore but like
health how to meet women hypnosis
manifest money that's really big on
there so and there's a ton of
different offers and the big part of
clickbank or i'd say
probably 99 of it is affiliate marketing
so a lot of these guys will send emails
to you know the top performing offer and
make their you know there's an email
swipe like the which means that the
email is pre-written
uh so you know someone can get this
pre-loaded email
send it to their list not everyone uses
the pre-loaded email but most do
and then you get the clicks and you make
money so when i see brian rose sending
me some kind of uh
tikka tuary stock picking deal that's
what's going on
he's got an affiliate deal yeah
right so they might have a variety of
products clearly you know this industry
really well so why'd you turn your back
on it so i mean kind of what i just
explained it is one
it's sort of one reason why i did it so
i kind of
about six years into it
i mean at first it gets incredibly
seductive
at first talk about that why the money
the money and how fast it is and the
world kind of seems like
i mean i came so i'm originally from the
car business so i kind of more like
traditional background
to these guys sales um yeah sales side
and i you know and i was also working
the management side of
you know the car business so you know
when you get into when like when i first
walked into dallabadas i walked into
like a basement
you know it's like these weird people
walking around and they're like
i'm like what are they doing like they
can't be making
any money or anything and all of a
sudden you see that they're they're
making a ton of money and you're like
how is this even possible
like how can they do this it's like this
rag tag bunch of
weirdos and fundamentally what a lot of
them are doing are just
writing they're just writing like sales
letters right
yeah in some sense yes in some sense
no so it's right now it's more or less
sales letters like tennis years ago they
they were
trying to create products but then it
was kind of morphing into sales letters
that were starting to win out
um because you can't you can just
the thing is you can just write
technically sales letters
so a lot like backup to clickbank
they're basically writing
they're really working on their email
marketing their affiliate email
marketing
and way more so now because i think the
average customer
lasts on a list for them for about four
to seven days
so like they get a new customer then
after seven days they're burned burned
you know
they're no longer buying products you're
right
because they think it's because all they
are they're using the products
like no you you [ __ ] idiot i don't
know if i can swear on here but it's
it's because you you sent them 30 offers
in four days like what do you think is
gonna happen
yeah you unsubscribe from it and all the
filters now are programmed to get rid of
those
they just kick over the to the spam
folder anyways so what i got out of so
when i got into it it gets
it gets very seductive because it's
um
won the money like it you know for me i
was a copywriter it's cool seeing
something like i wrote something and all
of a sudden
you know i stunk at it for a bit or i
did okay for a bit then all sudden one
thing
hits you know and it's just like you're
playing golf and you hit that one
huge monster drive out of the blue and
you're like oh my god
and then that is you kind of get
seductive you're doing it again and
again
then you go to an event like traffic and
conversion
and you see it's just like these random
people and
at first like you kind of believe
they're making this amount of money and
some of them
are making a ton of money but usually
the ones who are making a ton of money
aren't
bragging about it and then i you know i
started working in
you know on the health side with like
venus fact and yoga burn and it's
it kind of triggered for me when i wrote
for yoga burn because i kind of
um i didn't want to i didn't want to
affiliate market the list but then i was
kind of starting to
like why are we sending like in the it
kind of came to me like the car business
like
it would be like me selling someone a
car
right they just bought a they just
bought a 4runner
great while you're in the waiting room
for your 4runner i'm now going to
introduce you to the dealership across
the way
and they're going to sell you a chevy so
get ready
and then he's gonna sell you some then
once if you buy that chevy
then we have the honda guy who's coming
like sure
what are we doing this is silly yeah
so and then like that was part of it and
then it was kind of
um you know when i was like if some of
these offers i wrote or the emails
things that i wrote it's just like this
is complete [ __ ] uh well that
that's the biggest part of it is a lot
of these offers the copywriter's
language gets so far away from what
actually is true right right right
i mean it depends so like if you're on
like if you're playing with bigger
numbers you're on google you
and there is [ __ ] but you can't well
your claims can't be like you're gonna
you know
eliminate 84 pounds of fat in one week
like you can't say that
you know or you can't do what like you
know what like wesley virgin did
with you know using a stock photo and
kyle cooper as a
you know from you know you can't do that
right
you can't steal your stock photos from
uh jenny craig which is part
so you have to kind of be on the up and
up wait are you saying he stole his
stock photos from jenny craig
yeah he did at first yeah and then he
took them
but the big the saddest thing was he
used a personality called kyle cooper hi
i am marine gunnery sergeant kyle cooper
and i'm about to share a bizarre story
with you
it was a military hero well again guess
the name
chris kyle you know the actual you know
famous
military sniper military hero
and then bradley cooper who played him
in the movie and then he made the name
kyle cooper and he found a stock photo
of a bald guy that had like a military
photo
and added some family then he just crop
some hair on the guy
um you know and it was some story of
like you know some binder
came out and friend into dying arms and
hailing but this i mean the offer did
well
but um so it was kind of like i mean
at first i was definitely seduced by
this world because i was like oh my god
you know and they really buy into sort
of like
they look like napoleon hill concepts
like you think you're making money
so you you're providing value to the
world that's huge to these people
like they love napoleon hill and they
love anne rand
um the two the two idols
right and napoleon hill was you know was
a scam and
like but they revere like that's a big
part of the mindset with a lot of these
these groups i mean coming back to the
stories that i was mentioning like you
know
we're creating like a story and we're
just changing it so much that it's not
true anymore
like a hero's journey story and it's
just about the conversions
and then being in and sitting you know
kind of somewhat sipping that kool-aid
and sitting inside these masterminds
and then people are you know they got
kicked off of google
facebook amazon probably 8chan and
they're trying to like
wonder how they can get back around and
they're missing that they broke
like you got kicked off of like the
entire
internet because you lied maybe
yeah it's like well you know that well
then they would say well it's because
it's anti
it's their anti like people on goo
people who own google are anti
making money like you know so they get
into this weird stick
or or it's you know the you know donald
trump is out to get them or hillary
clinton is out to get them so all these
weird theories like i don't think
hillary and donald are really concerned
what you're doing like
with your fat loss supplement maybe it's
because you're lying
and cheating people out of their
hard-earned money
then yeah then they backpedal more into
like it's helping people
you know so these people really kind of
buy into their own
[ __ ] a lot of them do yeah not the
big huge huge players but a lot of them
do um really go like that like talking
to me
yeah well it's a little bit too full i
mean one i mean i'll be
you know sound like a snob but like
they're just really dumb like dum da dum
dum dum and they found
a formula to make money and you can make
money with it
you know they they miss how short term
it is and how much they're scrambling in
their life to do it
the other thing is they're so bought
into like the positive thinking
mindset element there were any critical
thinking or any questioning of it is
considered toxic thinking
you know they'll start throwing out you
that like the product graveyard is
filled with great
products that weren't ever marketed
which is a fallacy because
wyoz isn't a great marketer just go to
the product graveyard and find one of
these like
you know it's a it's a it's just they
swallow these pills
of oh you make money it provides value
or it's just a hustle
you don't you don't need to think about
it you just gotta hustle and you know so
they really bind the
positive mindset kind of thing to the
extreme i mean nothing wrong with a
positive mindset
but they're kind of the people who would
focus on like lebron james's
shoe tying routine as his reason for
success
and then the post game interview of like
well you know we tried hard i mean he's
exhausted he's not giving like detailed
answers of like the passes he was giving
he's just gonna give something off the
top of his head
so they really buy into like growth
themed advice
and anything questioning that they view
as like
toxic thinking or a victim mindset or
you're slowing down the process
i don't watch tv because i'm consuming
content like they didn't
yeah so i don't know if that explains it
but that so basically they buy into all
these platitudes
so much that they never stop and think
that maybe
what their the whole idea of the secret
the law of attraction isn't as true as
they bought into
maybe it's there's more technical
reasons for this
and because of that you're saying they
never question what they're doing from
an
ethical place because that's what i ask
all these people and they look at me
like
it's the first time they've ever thought
about it or been asked the question i go
how can you do this to people
and it's like they're like deer in the
headlights and they're gonna backpedal
onto well i'm making money so i'm
providing value or they may not say i'm
making money providing value but they
think because they're
they miss it they're extracting money
it's basically like like
you know like rent seeking like they're
they're just extracting money one way
they don't under and they think because
they're making you know
they're living their aunt randy and
dream like that that makes them somehow
like they're
they're superior like i'm hustling you
know i'm just going to dig into my
augmentino book and i'm going to hustle
some more
so getting back like when i left yeah
one it was kind of the
unethical aspect of it and i think like
you know seeing
certain like women in the midwest who
generally who
they're not dumb they're just so
desperate to lose weight or genuinely
want to lose weight
and you know these things are some of
these sales letters are
so calculated so well written it sounds
so real uh and the products and we
talked later about how the products
created but the you know
but the products stink you know they buy
it and then then they're hammered other
people
you know they're hammering all this
affiliate stuff and then the other
element was
um i saw people with like the best of
intentions
with good products although it's really
rare on clickbank to find a good product
but
like a good product and they just
either you know they get seduced by the
marketing world by like the traffic and
conversion
when they see someone like venus factor
i'm just an offer away i'm just an offer
away from these guys i can like them
they're going to vegas and they got you
know a penthouse i i'm just an offer
away
um or the other ones they get sadly
leashed
to it and they can't go outside of it
like there's probably people who could
probably
get off this you know this
merry-go-round and like start a blog or
a vlog or something
and do it much more organically but then
they
you know oh it's too slow i'm not going
to make any money so they're just like
miserably like i'm just gonna hang on
and
do this for as long as i can and milk
this for as long as i can
you know what's funny about what you're
the the picture that you're painting
is that there's a lot of these uh guru
types copywriter types these
really people who are sort of scamming
other people who
are themselves sort of getting scammed
by the people
who are it's like they're selling
shovels right they're selling get rich
to people who are not rich but they
themselves are getting sold
other types of shovels with like russell
brunson selling click funnels all the
time
saying that's gonna change your life
you've got people who'd you say ryan
ryan ryan dice yeah this whole
group of of uh
like they're also getting sold to
and they're being told well you're only
one offer away
and those people are telling their
customers that you're only one
purchase away like it's like a pyramid
scheme almost
right of success everyone's selling each
other's success
it's insane right this is insane and
they don't understand like
and that's kind of the like with ryan
dice like
one i mean he's really paid to polish
his image now he's saying that he's he's
probably gonna get after me
you know like frank kern and him are
like if you say hey ryan your hair is
out of place he's like
defamation um all right
okay um you know so they understand that
you know the people who are not you know
who are low on software projects or on
page 30 of clickbank
are going to be their audience so
they're going to sell them
the tactics um and russell i think does
a little bit better job because russell
can sell like
there's always going to be those those
make get rich quick
gurus but russell definitely has like
like a lot of these guys wouldn't exist
now without
russell and like if russell stopped
i mean they'd be like drug addicts at
the door like ah
tell me my next trick russell
what do i this time russell
yeah exactly so you know they
they kind of just sell these guys and
they just believe i'm just one thing
away and then some of them obviously do
find a bit more success
like so they buy then they get into the
masterminds
and then the mastermind basically is
like you know buying
what kind of rolex can i buy that's
really it becomes about oh yeah i'm like
i'm blowing like three or four
masterminds like
okay i'm living my best life
cool um but
they think like i'm in this mastermind
it's going to
generate my success so they like they
kind of remove all sense of agency they
hand it over and ryan and russell know
these people are going to come to them
and they're going to sell them the whole
thing like
like russell's mastermind and how to
start a mastermind or something
the funniest thing ever a mastermind on
how to
for people who want to make a mastermind
for how to sell a mastermind
that's what i'm interested in oh it's
out there i'm sure it's got to be out
there and
you know some inner circle club or
something but like russell's a showman
he's really good at what he does like he
knows his crowd when he walks caleb
maddox out on stage
and russell understands marketing like i
don't think he's super malicious but he
knows when kayla maddox comes out on
stage these people are going to be like
oh you know some guy who's like craig
valentine's gonna sit there and be like
oh man uh he's 18
he's emo you know he's not going to
check the claims like he's a multi-mega
millionaire like you know it might be
his
dad's things and other things so he's
making money he's like oh that means i
can be a billionaire if i just try
harder russell knows that craig
valentine is going to sit there
and think that he's going to sit there
and think that
so it's kind of like this guilt sales
thing like russell's just like oh yeah
caleb's going to get me some big sales
because he's 18. and they're going to
look at this like and it's like a
jealousy thing like
almost like and also the positive
thinking oh if caleb maddox can do it i
can do it
and so all these guys are buying into
that whole world
you saw that and that also made you kind
of get disillusioned with it you saw all
these people on a treadmill
of like hunting for success and not real
a lot of them not
exactly finding it right so i kind of
saw that and then i thought people like
you know who kind of like we mentioned
with jason kind of struggled with their
other offers they they weren't
they weren't struggling they were making
a living but then they suddenly move
into selling success
and it's like what do you you know and
they're just you know they're picking up
the hottest buzzword burke
like start with why and just repeating
it um
you know and then they get into like
these entire like circle jerk things
like
like the next up is dan lok the next up
is pedro's trulian the next up is this
guy and they
they're all just sharing the prophets
like and all they do is just mention
each other
um so i kind of wait you're telling me
they're not all great friends who love
each other
you're kidding they probably did i
thought these guys
yeah yeah yeah they
but you know they got to pay the stage
for you to get up there and share the
things so
i mean you know what's funny to me is
you say all
a lot of these guys are really stupid
who would you say
is the dumbest of all the gurus if you
had to
put it your thumb on somebody oh man
i think when arthur is gonna be clark is
gonna take the cake
nice you guys if you don't know i'll put
some links in the description for uh who
this guy is
he sold he sold harvard offers like
speak at harvard and speak at cnn now i
understand you had a bit of a run-in
with clint
yeah i did i run out with clint and uh i
uh
so i went to a dan kennedy event a dan
only event which actually
is is not a bad event so clint and i had
never met clint before
but i sat next to him for a couple of
days um
and he's always pitching you know his be
famous thing you get to be famous the
whole purpose of being famous so i'm
flying back in the
cleveland airport and i see him and i'm
just being friendly oh hey
i saw you at the event what'd you think
of the event and he starts going into
the shtick
he's like you could be famous i was like
cool like he said you have like why
don't you speak at harvard you could
speak at harvard i'm like i don't speak
in a harvard time with speaking at
harvard like
it's like no man don't you want to be
famous don't you want to be known i'm
like
no is he really saying this don't you
want to be famous he's saying that i
could make you famous i can make you
famous
yeah he's like you think of it think of
all the attention you could get holla
and you could sell your products like
are you a good copywriter i can make you
more famous this is a better copyright
i'm like no
i'm i'm happy where i'm at we're doing
good like
he's like oh man that's not the attitude
to have so then i'm like
politely i'm like look just give me your
email you know maybe
we'll talk later so that was a mistake
so i give him my email then he emails me
you know i'm kind of checking on the
phone like hey i got it thanks
well he emailed you right there he's
like sitting there emailing you
right there but he emailed me he put me
on his list
so i got the his welcome email not like
him being a normal person be like hey
man here's my email
it puts me on a list like right away and
i'm like
dude and so i'm trying to get away from
it's like yeah you could really be
famous
so i'm going to the bathroom and walk in
the bathroom and also have the urinal
next to me like he comes up and
leans in he's like you could be famous
and i'm like
then i just told him to [ __ ] off like
i'm like there's gonna be a whole
different problem
if he if he keeps up you know accosting
me in the bathroom i said look there's
gonna be a
huge [ __ ] problem it takes me a lot
to get mad but i was like getting ready
to
to sock him i'm like there's gonna be a
big problem if you don't back the [ __ ]
off
and i was yelling kind of loud then
eventually he kind of got it like
um yeah so that wasn't like he's like no
problem no problem no problem but uh you
know harvard would love to see this
yeah so he's he's dumb i mean i think
like
i know i pick on him a lot like craig
valentine
um i don't know i don't even know who
craig valentine is i don't know who that
is
he's it's just buzzword and like mr
buzzwords
but he i don't think he's that no he's
not that dumb
he's not as dumb as clint um
he's just he believes too much in his
own stuff but you know like i saw these
guys and
there was just something about it this
didn't sit right with me and
yeah eventually i kind of found
philosophy
and then i said i'm out of it i can't do
it
i can't do this anymore i can't make it
like that you started you were thinking
for yourself and you realize hey maybe
there's not
maybe i shouldn't be doing this what was
it
i mean it was it was a culmination of a
lot of things like i mean i love stoke
philosophy but it was kind of the
critical thinking element of it
and then it was kind of like in stokes
blossom they had something called
i mean uh that called like a choice or
the
you're making a choice that serves the
whole so basically
you know when it comes down to try to
make a choice that
honestly serves the whole so you're
being transparent and i was like there's
something off
here that you know me creating or
consulting on some story about some
secret you know ancient rare herb for a
five-hour boner you know like this isn't
this isn't real and then and then seeing
you know then seeing some of these
you know make money online gurus and i
think i kind of saw that before
just the nature of the car business i
was like well
you know kind of me i'm a pretty curious
person so seeing how they're making the
money at these events like that
i would think i was lucky to kind of be
looking at that right away
to be like this is kind of a suckers
game here to be sitting here so how are
they making the money
um you know versus the guy like shushing
me he can't wait to hear this nlp secret
he's like got his notebook out writing
it all down yeah yeah yeah
right which is more signaling because
they're hustling you know they got to
take as
many notes as they can because they're
hustling yeah and the you know the the
si
and plus the other end that i saw was
being in it for so long like venus
factor was successful for a number of
reasons
and also one of the owners of a
venus factor he comes from from one of
the wealthiest families in canada
oh so he has money to fall back on for
this ad spend and that's not a bad thing
like he
he's very smart at what he does
but he can he can fall back on things so
he has kind of a safety net and i was
kind of seeing like these people will
get
um you know like they'd like dallas
badass i mean half of me most of the
people that worked with
a badass are broke you know living in
their sister's basement so i saw a lot
of these guys who
make a ton of money like get to the top
of clickbank
or get to the page or somewhere else not
always clickbank but do
really really well for about three-ish
years and then boom bro
gone vanish company out of business and
they're like you know the revered is
doing everything right
i'm like there's something off here and
then me knowing like you know the
copywriting with all the hooks and
seeing all like the bad copy and stuff
i'm like this is just
like the copywriters aren't
understanding what they're doing
is like they're just trying to come up
with a crazy story but but it converts
yeah but it's not true right maybe we
should be a little more specific with
the audience of like what kind of
stories we're talking about here
they're pretty formulaic walk us through
you mentioned the five
hour the five hour boner let's hear more
about that because that's like a real
that's a real story they would try to
sell
is like and this is not a lie you'd
click on one of these
scam links of like oh doctor finds
mysterious thing
and then you'd read like a headline now
how does this arc
usually go of this
so there's a couple of variations the
most common one i'm seeing right now
i mean like you know there's a the agora
formula
which is you know uh basically wild
conspiracy theory they don't
have the five hour bone or stuff but and
probably somewhere
it was somewhere oh it's a conspiracy
theory like about pharma or what
yeah they'll do pharma or they'll do
like you know hillary clinton
planted a a rogue inside of donald
trump's cabinet
you know and i'm the only person who
knows this like okay
then so there's their formula then
hasn't been done in a while but
uh john benson uh kind of came up with a
what's called the pattern interrupt
formula
uh which is hi my name is josh and this
is a goldfish and this fish is gonna get
you laid so immediately you say
something kind of odd
um to try to like the whole idea is
you're going to tap into their mind
so it's kind of like a you know kind of
like a mentalist trick if you do
something really on the kind of like
pause the brain for a second like what a
fish is going to help me get laid like
that's the whole
goal like so it doesn't serve the story
for that it's just to get you to kind of
like
hey wake up you would try to do it
like the goldfish one we talked about
like how like goldfish mating patterns
and have to have a goldfish if they had
multiple women around it
would be more desirable so some people
try to pay it off
a lot of people don't try to pay it off
now
the other in the other big version um
and probably the more popular one now is
like story selling is a hero's journey
and generally what you do is you know
that one is
is and i see that one get abused the
most like the kyle cooper thing so
basically
and you see like my sister was you know
500 pounds and was having a heart attack
on the plane
and you know and all of a sudden the
daughter you know like the first line of
the bsl be like mama
please live mama that was you know the
word of my
wife as she laid on the hospital bed at
584 pounds
about to die she was only 29 years old
and she had tried everything to lose
weight so like like that
like that's the pi that's kind of a
popular one and i even see agora kind of
using that
that message now like you know i was my
my father-in-law was on the plane and
you know he had a massive heart attack
and at 784 pounds like
this is true this is not true yeah and a
binder hit me on the head and i
put a rare herb inside of his mouth
you know wouldn't you know it ten days
later he lost
the weight
[Laughter]
so but these are first
so what they do is they they take
they take the story right but then
they start with a swallow thing like the
uncle
squeeze squeeze into the plane aisle all
right that's 784 points yeah
um always on like a transatlantic flight
of course like right now
we're i was hoping to take him to see
you know the
louvre you know like oh god okay
grab your river you know um
so like and then they have this um
you kind of come up with this crazy
story and then what you want to do is
you know the better guys it's hard to do
you take the person
you know you so one you start them off
like you know so it's kind of what's
called an open loop so the guy's on a
plane
you know or on a hospital bed and you
know little
little little sally's saying all
saccharine stuff and
um and then you know you take the person
you kind of take them back to the
beginning like they tried everything
and if the person's at weight loss sex
were like i didn't understand it myself
i've helped
a hundred thousand people get ripped
shredded and lean
you know so they you know throw in this
stuff but my sister i tried everything
you know her metabolism had slowed down
the doctors kept
so then you try to like during the story
you show how
like you want to make the whole goal
isn't as taught at these marketing
or copywriting things is make the person
be telling the story of whether it's
yourself or someone else
um you know a sister or someone or just
make up a sister which is what you know
fat diminisher i think
raposo made up made up his sister i
think um
so you take someone and then you make up
the story and you make them to the worst
possible they had tried everything
rebound weight gain so you're trying to
check off these boxes and be the same
thing as making money online right so
these guys
apply the form of there like i tried
this and i lost 5 000
i tried good i tried amazon i tried
facebook
right i tried this and then you kind of
want to make them win
again like they tried 5 000 and i you
know
i said in one key lines i was going to
die trying
that's a key line that's been used all
the time um
supposedly that's because of the dallas
badass video i don't know i know
a version that but that line is used all
the time i was gonna never give up and
die trying because most people think
that they're
you know their jocko will nick and
they're never gonna give up like a lot
of people
you know it's what we want to tell
ourselves right right so everyone's
reading that like oh he's not
gonna die trying and this guy's so bad
so you know they
so then they put him back down again and
depending on the video sales that are
you know you could put the person down
like three or four times and they they
will
test how many times you're going to put
the person there they're almost there
and then they finally give up but then
it's a catch-all moment either
you know they're on a plane flying you
know to see just one last time to see
the louvre and you know he
has a heart attack or something and then
this of course it's one dumb trick
or i decided to go on this research
bound i drank coffee i didn't sleep for
days
and i found this mysterious researcher
who decided to
like you know and i found this
rare herb and people thought i was crazy
and then it kind of worked at first and
then all of a sudden i found a 10 second
morning trick you can do each and every
single morning
and all of a sudden not only do the
weight fall then you know so you kind of
then you know you find the person like
see you you knock out the doctor's
objection
you knock out the rebound weight gain or
i lost i i made money but then i lost
money objection
uh or i tried seo ads but then i
couldn't quite
figure it out so you kind of find these
key objections
you put the person through it and you
make them worse than the three stooges
going at a at everything like they just
i mean
they're poor yeah dumb you know like
or they're you know they they try a
weight gain or weight loss
the most popular you know they try p90x
and keto and they put on 450 pounds you
know
um and you know they tried calorie
counting and
you know and the calorie counting only
made them fat and they thought they had
only
carrots like so that you know you put
them through and then you finally give
them this then you start selling the
solution
you know and you kind of then when you
get into the solution of the story
you're kind of then you
you switch to hard selling you don't
really tell them the solution
you don't tell them that the products
are a couple of things you kind of
searched on pubmed or google
um you know so but that's how the story
that's how kind of more the story
selling goes and sometimes they even try
to do it on email sequences
um you know and i've seen edgier
versions now like the guru is trying to
be like look i was [ __ ] down just
like you
but i didn't listen to my excuses you
[ __ ] lose you're like
you know um so like that's what
that's what dan pena does that's his
whole pitch it's like you're a loser
your mother
your mother and father it was all a big
mistake they're losers and you're gonna
die a loser just like them if you don't
listen to me
what's up with that are people just
wanting a dad or what
uh there's a there you know it's
an article error i'm currently editing i
kind of
trying to cover because it is
interesting right like you
you pay 5 000 bucks to go listen to some
creepy old man call you a [ __ ] loser
or i love like or garrett
yeah or garrett white has this hefty
dude call you you know
you can't lose weight because you're
[ __ ] driven by your excuses you lose
you're like
look who's talking there boss like
um like i don't see you powerlifting or
anything
you know so what what's your deal but
i think the thing is there's definitely
a kind of a common edge now
or it's sold to them to be a little bit
edgy
not as familiar with whether if there's
more wizard behind dan
pena screen but it's sold to them to be
more edgy
like you know the subtle art you know
not that mark manson intended this
with his book but the subtle art of not
giving a [ __ ]
suddenly you know and uh you know and
other books came out with swear words
suddenly inside the guru world
we can now swear and some people really
took on an edgy persona like everyone
saw like tony robbins drops an f-bomb
but
him dropping an f-bomb it's not as
noticeable but dan payne is
screaming at you like you know an old
man or uh
you know or garrett white comes up with
his tattoos and says it you know [ __ ]
450
yeah gary vee does this too he's like
it's cause i'm real i'm real i
i swear because i'm real so this
edginess matters and then i think
you know a part of this market is like
well i need to hear it
i'm here to get tough talk like it's not
that these people are dumb but they
think like you know they kind of think
they're like
like it's a navy seal type of thing like
you know what this is the stuff i need
to hear
it's it's an odd dichotomy of you know
at events they stand up to signal to
hear the tough talk
and there's always gonna be one guy like
you know what i was just like you and i
listened to
uncle dan pena up here and now
i i'm a millionaire you know i beat my
excuses
you know or there's a guy who's like i
lost a pound and then you see them a
year later he's still obese like he's
but the secrets
are going to work for him at some point
like
so there's this weird signaling method
and i think as far as more back to like
you know if they're not at an event it's
just someone's like this is
this is real talk i need to hear this
like they're they're not
so usually it's a first-time person
generally it's someone who does want to
improve so we have to commend that like
they're well intentioned because they're
reaching for some type of improvement of
something
right themselves their business their
relationships
whatever it is you know and these guys
are some of them are really good
marketers
so you know but then like
you know when kind of the populator of
hearing the f word like yeah
you know i i can't i can't get up
earlier it's only it's a [ __ ] excuse
if i hit the snooze button like it feels
great but it's just a like a placebo
motivational
effect let me ask you this so
there's obviously a lot of people who
don't know what they're doing now there
are a few people who do know what
they're doing
uh one that obviously comes to mind is
uh
agora one of the biggest direct response
marketing companies in the world maybe
the biggest
are they are they actually the biggest
they might be right i think they are i'm
almost certain as far as direct
responses
in their manner they they have to be
yeah they do like a billion dollars i
mean it's something
almost yeah in insane
a billion people take a billion and a
half in profit or something yeah
which is just absolutely mind-blowing
off of all these what are essentially
scam
like promos of like hey the bible hidden
inch
mark iv was this secret cure to cancer
if you just listen
and like my question is this look
obviously they know their target market
is like old conservatives for a lot of
their offers
do these writers i mean they must target
that stuff because like i see god
mentioned a lot in a lot of their ads
they're doing that on purpose like they
know right they like they know oh this
will get him
if we hit him with the old god factor is
that what
yeah they yeah so they
they very much study their their avatar
you know
or their direct or their target market
right so generally
you nailed it you know older
conservative
very much scared of dying
you know they don't want to die so they
want their money protected or they want
their you know they want the health care
they just don't want to die
in hospice or something like they're
just frightened
so they know that and generally they're
going to be generally or more religious
markets so they're
you know so how agora works is
you know they have a couple of top guys
a couple of top riders
who have had massive huge hits and then
they basically have monkeys on a
typewriter
um you know yeah here is our formula
which is you have a crazy like
you know adolf hitler put this away you
know and actually to cure
covet and all this by the way guys this
is not that far off the real thing
i know it sounds if you've never heard
this stuff it sounds
unbelievable and insane this is really
what a lot of these
ads like are kind of like it's very it's
very close yeah like
like the clubsy plague like that was a
big agora for the klebsie plague
what's that fuzzy plague i'm sure they
changed it now and probably put
something with kovad on it
but the clubs he played i mean they made
it sound like instant death
and hillary clinton or was behind it you
know hillary and obama conspired in a
back room
and uh you know and and trump's not
seeing it but we
we have the we have somehow the
information that
uh you know the club z plague is coming
so you know they will take like a
yo see these writers they have a formula
you know they'll take a crazy story like
that
like you know we found something hidden
in a world war two journal
you know like some guys you know find
something at you know a normandy or
something in a in a binder
or like or hitler kept some weird
medicine under wraps that could cure
things like
so they kind of buy into these
conspiracy theories and they will look
up particular conspiracy theories or
they will take up something like clubsy
plague
probably is going to like yeah probably
not great for
someone who's 85 to get klebsie play but
it's not like we're in the you know
the clubsy plague pandemic but they make
it sound like
it's coming um so then they will
and they know yeah they know to press
particular buttons with these stories
and a gore runs like 90 minute video
sales letters
and they don't drop the button so the
bot the button means a buy button until
the very very
end which is incredible
uh that they that they're able to to do
that
or the ability to make people stay that
long but they do a vid yeah it makes it
look like it's a conspiracy thing like
we don't know when the you know when the
government's going to shut up yeah you
don't even know it's a sale
until deep in you're like oh wait this
has
all been to try to sell me something
right and selling some type of like
monthly newsletter or some like weird
book with you know like a couple of
folks he cures like olive oil
or something or or you know some retired
hedge fund guy or not retire like they
just use they just use some guys
james altitude spills the secrets all
over the place
right um so they create so they
how they write those offers they start
with those offers first
they don't like find a product they will
find a name they'll find a researcher
that will rhetorically dance around but
they
will have that particular market
demographic and they will
hit on key things you know like the end
of america
is coming you know most old people are
concerned that yeah america's
ending so they're gonna you know they're
giving them yeah
they're giving them their life back
they're giving them money so that where
they're not gonna die
you know greeting at walmart or
something you know they're scared to
death of doing that for which makes good
sense so they have all these fears
they're pressing on spend time with my
grandkids maybe even see my grandkid
you know the first one to graduate
college can you believe that
like you know little skippy graduated
college and even get a little frisky
with my wife
of you know 58 years so they you know
they paint up this really golden age era
image that of protection you know in the
end after 90 minutes that you get a you
get a monthly newsletter but that
monthly newsletter means you're going to
get
sold other things like our folksy olive
oil pure to be coveted or
you know the tumeric uh the tumeric pill
to sleep better like
so they create this offer first it's all
about the offer then the product comes
later so what how are we going to do the
offer then a top writer over there
may some of them may write it themselves
but a lot of them like all right here is
20 monkeys in my group
that are writing offers here this is the
formula we're going to run it
then they you know they they test which
story works work
or works best okay you know the
researcher from arizona didn't work
let's try the the crazy doctor from uh
you know from texas
uh it's not going so good maybe let's
try the researcher with this thing
you know so they'll change the
personality they'll change the entire
story
to find one that hits and it's all
ultimately to get grandma to hand over
her social security check
at the end of the day yeah that's what
it's about or just pay you know
or pay just keep just get them paying
sure a lot however yeah but
if it's a social security check if it's
their you know their credit card where
their granddaughter is
supporting them or you know if they're
old and you know you know the guy put
you know he probably has you know maybe
10 million and 10 cans out back and you
know his farm in iowa like
and he's got a you know just how much of
that 10 million can we grab
always the question is is at what cost
i think in some ways getting seniors to
hand over
uh their dinero is one of the
things that most people don't care of is
a crime because
nobody wants to think of old people on
their deathbed because it's just sad
and that's why there's so much senior
fraud anyways it's because a lot of
these people are
senile or close to it and when you're
targeting these people like
you gotta be really careful because
there's so much
opportunity to basically fleece someone
blind um right
if they're not even they're they're not
even thinking that
like they're because they're so obsessed
with converge like
for the big problem with this world and
not just cigar and even like the guru
stuff but
i mean i mean but back to agora
is there it's so conversion based and
right back to this thing we mentioned
like they're making money therefore
they're making value
and no government anti-capitalist commie
or
no you know note where capitalist wall
street huckster
is going to tell me otherwise so this
odd libertarian thing
so they miss so that all those
conversions all those old people kind of
just become numbers on the screen
and that's so insidious and it's like
it's what you said
it's they've lionized making money they
think it's the perfect
they think if they're making money
they're therefore moral
and they don't understand that bernie
madoff made money
he made a lot of money charles ponzi
made a lot of money
these are not good people right i mean
and madoff knew what he was doing but
the agora people don't i mean some of
them
do like the more up the more i mean just
like the ryan dice is the russell
brunson not that
dicer brunson or being as aggressive as
those guys nowhere near it
um like i i would have a hard time you
know i mean russell understands what
agora does and that he just he loves
conversions but not
the point where it's you know all hail
conversions
uh you know so these guys like they they
i mean even some of the copyrighters if
you pose them that question
some of them are just going to look at
like well if they followed it and it
worked it could work you know their
studies show
that you know like you know so they kind
of start
getting into like this like platitude
speak
of it could work um look it's not on me
we sold them something that could work
like they don't didn't they read the
disclaimer at the bottom
[Laughter]
exactly so they miss it it is what it is
and that's kind of when i
you know got out of this stuff it was
like it's just pure money extraction
you know and they are yeah they're
taking advantage of older conservative
uh you know males and females and
extracting money from them and counting
money let's talk about claims
right one thing i want to talk about is
the ability for these writers to make it
sound like
they're you mentioned tumeric or
colloidal silver or
oregano herbs sun-dried in the uh
in panama you know they have this
ability
and i've watched it and it's kind of
amazing to
say that they can cure cancer cure heart
disease
cure alzheimer's cure all these things
and make then implant that in your mind
that it can do all these things
without ever saying that can you speak
to
how they dance legally around these
issues because obviously
they're not allowed to technically say
they can't say the words
oregano cures diabetes but they can
dance around it
with words like oregano has been proven
to lower blood sugar
or blood sugar irregularities or like
you know you know what i mean like they
know how to get around
the legal things can you talk about that
so there's a so there's a couple of
things to that
so one it's called so one thing we could
probably call those
and it's not quite tied to what you said
but uh well i guess it is
so something called stretch claims
now a standard so first a standard
stretch claim
generally has to do with with kind of
manipulating
numbers or manipulating a study to make
it
sound amazing right so real quick like
like tribulus is that you know that's
always solace something to like
you know crank testosterone in men
if you actually find the study like one
rat took it from tribulus in 1977
and mounted the other rats like we don't
know if that actually boosted the
testosterone the rat the rack just could
have been horny at the time right
so like but you know so
in a copyright with a good copywriter or
you know all right you know we'd see
these things and like well we can't say
0.01 we're gonna have to find a way to
say 10
more or a hundred percent more in a
sense like even like like gillette might
use it
with like this is a you know the razer
has now voted superior to the number one
razor but they're
they're saying it in the small print
compared to our other razor
right so the stretch claim is to take
anything
like a number like you know somehow like
point zero zero four and like how can we
turn this into four hundred percent
uh maybe copywriter maybe the copywriter
mistakenly
saw it as 4.0 okay like that's
we're sorry we'll change it to a 40
percent difference
right so stretch claims generally go
with with
numbers and you know in the second after
i
answer your question here but yeah i'll
touch base and kind of like
guru stretch um
so but back to like the rhetorical
dancing around
now the top offers like on agora or
like you know we sound like a top
offering clickbank that's running on
media like venus factor
or these other like big huge like
humongous health offers even more like
standard more normalized companies like
audit or something like that right
they have to be careful of what they are
saying agora gets blacklisted really
quickly online but most other people
like
they they will take a study on pubmed
like that's the breeding ground for
you know a lot of us [ __ ] is pubmed
they find yeah one study from yeah the
the 60s
and they transform it into a hidden cure
right yeah
right like three people took ashwagandha
and one person
you know slept better wow
like um so what they do
so the more the better rhetorical ones
or the probably the more mainstream ads
they're going to say like something like
a right oregano and the copywriter
knows like and i don't know like you
know when we were writing
or correcting videos on on google hey
this isn't google compliant
we would have to come up with things
like um
uh has been shown could possibly
be said to or what you would do is and
you see this often is you would
take a quote of a doctor you don't
know the doctor the doctor never said it
to you
and you say one doctor from harvard says
oregano has been shown to have health
benefits
now what does that doctor mean well this
other researcher says benefits could be
you know lowers your blood pressure now
things have been
shown that this oregano formula that we
put together
may help you lower blood sugar and not
only does it help lower blood sugar so
they will start stacking the claims on
top of it
and make it seem like they're connected
but they're actually not
right so it makes it seem like it looks
like
like most people watching it are gonna
they're not gonna notice the the
rhetorical dance of like
we heard a harvard doctor say like
that's one we heard a harvard doctor say
well where did you hear him say it like
you know was he
was he out drinking scotch one night and
he's like oregano
like um you know so it's like we heard
or we you know
studies have shown in particular dr
x from stanford so they'll take
something from pubmed
they will find one of the researchers
names or one of the doctors names
associated
or one of someone like associated and
this has been shown to
help reduce lower cholesterol
and then before that now if the claims
now sometimes like a copywriter will i
mean yeah there was at one point where i
would grumble be like i can't say it
does this
and then the hash shown is going to make
it look weak
so then when you see that you're going
to have to change something earlier in
the story
to make it sound to kind of undercut the
doctor's claim that doctors really don't
want you to know this but they might
kind of
grumble it out but they're not supposed
to tell you because big pharma is behind
them like you know like
you make it so like obviously a big
farmer has issues
the big pharma isn't in some like you
know some doctor is he might be squeezed
by a big farmer but he isn't like hey
hey
you know big pharma like that guy don't
worry i'm not telling him about olive
oil like you know
i mean but we're gonna make it like a
copywriter we're gonna make it
sound like that is kind of the case okay
right you have to be careful with that
though because you don't want to
suddenly start undercutting all doctors
or
undercutting a guru or whatever you
don't want to undercut
the known method and then show and then
start quoting the people because that's
that will
has been has been shown to hurt
conversions
um so you know you will take something
like you know
you'll take like the fake quote they
don't know the doctor they never made
anything it's probably something the cop
writer looked up in two seconds
uh you know before he you know
whatever read pt barnum books or
something um
you know he just looked it up oh look at
that doctor has said this then you'll
make it look like studies have shown
and one particular study showed a
drastic increase
well we found the formula to really
concentrate this
you know a an oregano or ashwagandha
thing into cranking out you know
testosterone or whatever so
you will start looking for ways to make
it sound like
you're either going to distract that it
has been shown to make it sound like a
doctor says
you know so you preface it with
something so all you say it's lowers
cholesterol
then you stack what's called stack
claims you stack claims behind it
so to make it not only sound like a you
know so the main
they may come in maybe uh for like
diabetes
they may come on on that but then you're
going to stack the claims of other
issues of diabetes like maybe lower sex
drive this increases the sex drive this
increases that this increases that
so you stack claims to give to kind of
bolster the weak like it's possible
it could help this
that's how you kind of rhetorically get
around do you ever see uh
that's really interesting do you ever
see people doing something where they're
almost doing like rhetorical hyperbole
to get around it where they're going so
over the top with the claim that it
can't be construed as factual
but the yeah putting it in the mind of
the person
that actually it really does this like
this will make your
blood sugar you know it'll destroy those
high blood sugar levels
obviously how's the ftc going to say
that's a
factual claim it's you can't destroy
blood sugar levels
but maybe it puts it in the mind of the
person that oh this is going to really
help me out
do you ever see that kind of thing yeah
so what in the yeah your spidey
sentences are
are bang on so you will actually take
words like destroy slaughter
annihilate um those are probably more
towards like a male market
oh that's fair enough yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know in the female market
you might be like you know what the
results leave you barren
i mean even though they may be 70 but no
woman in 70 wants to be like
baron you know like so you use these
particular kind of words near that but
you have to be careful where you place
things obviously you can't say like i
mean some people will like you know
wesley virgin will say something like
uh you know my mindset you know you
think this for 10 minutes and you'll
become a billionaire like
you know so he's he doesn't get it quite
but
um you know these other guys yeah or
i've done it like
you put a word near something like
slaughter destroy you kind of preface
those words so
you put it close enough and then you
kind of dance like has been shown
you know or you can say something like
this like you know
ashwagandha has been shown to lower
cholesterol
well in my opinion in my results in my
experience it destroys cholesterol
like you know i see i see
in my experience or one of our clients
you know then you have the testimonial
which it eats fat cells like
no no person says it eats fat cells like
so you will pick these particular words
based on generally you want to do it if
you're smart
and you're trying to get them close
enough to where it sounds like it's
playing up that
that claim now something on google you
have to be careful
because you like one like destroy google
is going to
really notice that destroy like google
is getting smarter and smarter at this
but these you know it's just like
confidence artists they just get better
and better at
finding another rhetorical dance
um you know well i don't know what the
meaning of it has been shown
you know has been is this something new
jeez
first sorry i didn't mean to say that
your honor
yeah yeah so we'll so we'll change it so
they'll move those particular you know
words in a particular order
to try to make it sound like um
yeah you know you'll you know say you
know do this six step
system and you know you'll make you'll
be a millionaire in three months
or you know this uh ashwagandha you know
just just just
laser spat off your body it's an
unbelievable industry that you and i are
both sort of
wrapped up in i again i just find it
fascinating sort of your angle on it
um yeah it's a unique world that's for
that's for sure
well jim i think that's it what do you
have anything else uh you wanted to get
off your chest
while you're here what did you wanted to
tell me
i don't know it's always stuff but i
think uh
i think i got a lot off my chest there
so it was
this was a lot of fun yeah man thanks
for coming on the show thanks for
speaking out about this
i've been begging people to come forward
forever and listen let me do a little
shout out look at me look at the camera
right now so let me say this
if you work for agora and you just
happen to want to spill the beans you're
getting hungry you're getting antsy
you're saying hey this isn't right what
we're doing to people
i am welcoming all one and all uh
tips to my inbox you can find my email
address pretty easily please
come tell on your employer
just tattletail i'm asking you for
snitches
i'm pleased you're gonna get inundated
with people like you know
there's someone from agora pr is gonna
write you a script like our experience
is completely different and the american
dream is
you know still alive thanks to bill
bonner
yeah yeah exactly i'm watching you bill
hey
come to me even bill if you're tired of
your own uh
crap you can come and tell on yourself
you can tattletail dude i'll happily
take
your testimonial um yeah i just have to
say that because
that is one of the most secretive
companies and all of you working there
you know something's wrong
you know it i know all of you know it
it's like like you said it's a little
bit like stockholm syndrome they're all
just kind of
looking around like going hey is this
okay this is probably okay right and
everyone's like nodding to each other
yeah i think this is
okay right and you guys know it's not
okay
come to me i'll i'll make sure that make
sure that you're off the record we can
keep you anonymous
and uh yeah so that's it that's my pitch
so jim thanks for coming guys
jimclair.com
you can go find his blog you blog about
a lot of things including the gurus but
also about
just i think you blog about reading
right you have like a thing about books
and
you're a big fan of books which i
definitely like and uh
yeah man i really like what you're doing
nah thank you yeah that's been it's been
it's been a lot of fun to be on here and
reveal a little bit behind the curtains
so
on my ridiculous show uh great well
dude thanks for watching everybody
thanks for coming by
and uh we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
comes along